other games and pastimes such as apple
bobbing which is still associated with
Halloween today seems to have been a
part of the holiday even back in those
days and in general in these accounts
from around the 18th century it becomes
clear that the holiday was also
associated with what we could call
spooky stuff there are stories of
fairies kidnapping people on Halloween
night of witches hiding in the landscape
and terrorizing people but where indeed
did these scary aspects of Halloween
come from how did a holiday associated
with remembering the Catholic saints and
the diseased turn into a spook Fest
associated with spirits and witches well
partly as we saw it's probably a remnant
of the old sawin Festival where these
features seems to have been pretty
prominent many of these associations and
folk practices probably survived in
different ways across the centuries